I just don't have any time for it
anymore you know now I just feed into it
now I just I'm like yeah the lighter
stuff I'll just clap back and I'm like
let's go I know what that means for me
more downloads on the Pod and the more
downloads the more money I make it has
been two going on three years since you
exited Real Housewives of Beverly Hills
yeah what has been the greatest lesson
for you in the time away from the show
I think I've really found my voice I
think when I first started on housewives
you know I was the shell of myself
and I think that maybe it's through the
podcast or all the other different
things that I've done or just getting
more comfortable in my own skin
now I don't have that anymore yeah I was
going to ask how has doing two teas made
you think differently about your time on
the show or your place kind of in the
world of Housewives when I watch
I'm like oh I can see exactly what I'm
doing now timid I wasn't 100 comfortable
in what I was saying and doing and then
I'm like oh there's things I could have
done differently if I just would have
taken a breath is there one moment you
wish you could go back and change how
you handled it I wish I would have never
shown a cropped text message in Bahamas
about the dog the dog didn't Lisa want
you to tell me who yes from John
blizzard I wasn't even hiding anything I
was just hiding that it broke the fourth
wall and I just I'm like why did I show
I should just showed it right let
editors figure it out right but yeah
live and learn never crop your text
messages folks just send the whole thing
you had one of the most maybe the most
honest exits from the show so I could
give you the standard response of oh we
both came to the decision that would be
best yeah I'm not gonna do that that's
not who I am why do you think people
don't own that they're let go from the
show well I think already any form of
rejection it feels like projection when
all of a sudden you're not brought back
but I always have kind of will push back
at rejection with this is the truth and
this is me and what am I going to do
next
and like I want to I want to work hard
and figure out what the next thing is
which is why I think two T's in a pod
ended up being so successful because I
was like all right I'm gonna go all in
on doing this I want to bring Tamarin
and now we're over a year into it still
number one right yeah it's yeah it was
kind of a blessing in disguise I guess
of you're losing this thing that had
kind of become your identity and then
you get to transform it into this other
now I get to do it in a robe on zoom and
make more money it's actually fine
but pretty much since the day you left
there has been rumor and speculation
that Teddy's going to come back or for
some fear you're gonna come back
would you even want to at this point I
mean
no one really turns down a diamond but
it's not there are other jobs out there
there are other TV shows that I
would probably be better suited for me
at this time okay a very uh political
answer there yeah I mean I think what
else can I mean
no one's banging on my doorstep to come
back right now if an offer to join OC
with Tamara presented absolutely not
okay
I do not want an orange would you be at
all scared to film with Tamara knowing
how she operates in the housewives
Universe look at me
well you know I haven't seen past
seasons of OC and that's a constant
discussion that we have like should
Teddy go back and watch you should but I
almost feel like I need to go in not
knowing because like I have so much love
for Tamara and you know I can hold a
grudge well I don't Your Love Will
remains she invented the genre is what
you'll learn okay
but I think this season's gonna be a
real doozy for it we get in little
fights already so I'm like I don't even
want to have to talk about you now I'm
gonna get pissed I shouldn't have told
you this is why I didn't want to tell
you in Beverly Hills news what do you
make Lisa Brenna exiting and what that
means for the show moving forward I mean
I think a lot of people are going to
have to you know put in their time cards
now they're gonna have to punch their
punch their cards and get to work
because she did do a lot of it yeah and
whether you it bothered you to watch it
or you loved her it's something that at
some point to continue the show forward
somebody else is going to have to pick
up that slack who do you think needs to
pick it up the most I mean I saw an
interview that Sutton did and she said
you know I go to show up to work every
single day I'm going to work I'm like no
one's talking about that kind of work
don't pretend but I think that Sutton is
so good in her confessionals
that I want her to bring that same
energy
in scene to send actress and Lisa never
leaves her body it would take an
exorcism to get the safe actress out and
I want to see that same fire that I get
in the confessionals and yeah I mean I I
think they all know what they need to do
your girl Kyle likes to play with the
fans and say you know I think this might
be it time's coming to an end do you
think Beverly Hills could work and
continue without Kyle there I think that
Kyle is the glue that holds the girls
together so regardless of everybody's
obsessing over Kyle at the moment or
they're giving her a hard time you know
because now online people are so loud
that they overshadowed the actual fans
yeah
um but I truly think that she's the one
person that kind of even if there are
different groups within it she holds
everyone anytime your name comes up a
flood of hate comes with it how have you
learned to deal with that because I
think you are much better at dealing
with it now than you were when you were
holding a diamond well I think for one I
think there's a difference between
criticism and hate I can take criticism
but hate when it comes to like my body
or like an illness or my children or
whatever it may be that's why I I just
don't have any time for it anymore you
know now I just feed into it and I just
I'm like yeah the lighter stuff I'll
just clap back and I'm like let's go
yeah my Twitter feed is often half Teddy
Mellencamp
replying to somebody is it fun for you
does it like scratch an itch for you why
get involved there uh one because I I
know what that means for me more
downloads on the Pod and the more
downloads the more money I make people
don't realize engagement is engagement
whether it's positive or negative
positive or negative engagement is good
for me the second I'm trending people
whether I drive you to the point of you
know feeling the need to rage tweet
you're getting me the click so thank you
so much do you have a message for the
trolls like at Large
ah I mean nobody's gonna hate on you
that's doing better than you
this all started snowballing with your
exit and this increased scrutiny around
your business
do you wish you had been able to do one
more season of the show to kind of
control that narrative and share that
story well I wouldn't even say control
the narrative because there wasn't
really a story to it I wish in the in
the moment I was able to talk about it
but everybody was like No just don't
talk about it the more you don't talk
about it the more it'll go away but that
like all in is I live it and breathe it
and love it and like my heart that it
broke all of those things happened at
one time my daughter had neurosurgery I
got the boot from the show and then some
stranger on the internet started you
know attacking me and I just was like
this is a lot but I think that it's Made
Me Stronger and you know what I plowed
through did any of that outside noise
change at all how you operate the
business or think about the business
well I think always there's room for
growth within your business and there
were certain things that I was like okay
these are things I'm going to look into
or this or some things were complete
nonsense yeah what's the biggest
misconception about all in in the
program I think the biggest
misconception is it's about your
personal goals it's nobody's forcing you
to sign up I'm not walking around to
people's houses like are you gonna go
all in with me I'm gonna I want you to
change this and this about yourself no
you are going online you are signing up
for a program because you want to change
something about your life and you are
paying me and the women that work with
me to hold you accountable to doing that
we've said from the beginning we are not
doctors we've said this is what works
for us we all went through the program
that's why we you know it's the only
thing that's ever worked for me if it
doesn't work for you also let us know
and you can go and what's your message
to because it still gets regurgitated
that this is a dangerous program or an
unhealthy program what's your message to
that dialogue that's out there um it's
been the only thing that's ever worked
for me to not go into a dangerous and
unhealthy Place being held accountable
to taking the best care of myself that I
can showing up for myself if I didn't
have one of the women sending me a
message like hey Teddy you're gonna go
out for a walk today are you going to do
yoga are you gonna do that like I don't
I don't know where I'd be and I also
feel like the podcast has contributed to
finding your place in this world a
little bit what's been the rose and
thorn of the process for you
you know I Heart Radio had been asking
me you know since I had been let go from
Housewives we used to we talk about
Housewives we talk about Housewives can
we switch and I said only if I can have
a co-host and they were like okay and
they gave me some suggestions and I was
like no no no and they were like well
then who do you want I'm like I want
Tamara judge she also was recently fired
and so I called her and you know got her
to sign the deal and here we are who did
you say no to who was on that list I've
made I don't even I
well they wanted it two T's so that's
that's your hint or other teas you and
Tamara are both very unfiltered on the
podcast you share your whole opinion
good bad and ugly about everybody who
have you ticked off the most who's been
in your DMs the most complaining or
that's got word back to you of like they
do not like the things you're saying oh
I think Heather she was supposed to come
on well both Heathers actually the
Heathers oh apparently Heathers are not
into me sometimes but uh yeah both
Heathers where do you and Vicki
gunvalson stand right now I'm not
pitching the two cheese in a teapot
podcast right now well he we're talking
about the podcast okay let's just
she loves it I have a podcast with Teddy
you don't like Teddy Mellencamp I don't
know Teddy Mellencamp but I don't like
Teddy Mellencamp
oh you know Vicki is I was joking the
other day because Tamara and I were
talking about something and I was like
oh I need to check out Vicky and I went
to go look for her and she blocked me
and I didn't even know I can't even
stalk her oh no but I uh we're fine I
think she just
she she likes to give Tamara a hard time
and be like I don't want to talk about
the podcast I don't want this and I'm
just you know the low hanging fruit is
there anyone you will not invite on the
show I don't think I would personally
invite Camille on the show okay I mean I
I don't have the choice though I'm not
the boss so I mean I
there was somebody that said they would
come on not with me only with Tamara
though do you think doing the podcast
has affected your chances of doing
either going back to one of the shows or
doing an ultimate girls trip
I don't think so I mean I'm not I'm
obviously not on the girls trip right
now but um I think that it maybe has
opened more doors to like have more
conversations about it if you were
offered girls trip is there a Dreamcast
people you would like to see there and
on the flip side people you would not
like to see there I love Potomac so any
of those girls I would love to be with
um I think they would be fun to Miami
those girls are fun I all I mean I'm
fine with pretty much anybody as long as
I would like to be in a warm location
okay that's my wine request you don't
want to go I don't I love you Dorinda I
don't want to go to your house I also
don't want to go anywhere cold and what
about doing the Traders which is a cold
location but a competition and you could
win something or I could be voted out
first and then the online hate will just
go I I mean I think I'm pretty obsessed
with trade I'm not through it all but it
gave me a new appreciation for Brandy oh
yeah like she can clock I mean yeah I
love competition
foreign